avec le déconfinement s'est introduit
dans notre quotidien une nouvelle
routine celle du port du masque un
masque qui sert à protéger les autres et
à se protéger contre la propagation du
cobp id mais qui aujourd'hui pose un
autre problème d'ordre sanitaire car
dans les villes il n'est pas rare depuis
plusieurs semaines d'observer des
masques usagers jeter sans précaution
sur les trottoirs un geste anti civique
qui pourrait avoir des conséquences
graves
car en plus des dégâts écologiques ces
masques sont potentiellement infectées
et pourrait transmettre le virus à des
passants pour lutter contre cette
incivilité le député l'est républicain
erik projet de la 7e circonscription des
alpes maritimes souhaite déposer une
proposition de loi pour pénaliser les
mauvais élèves une amende qui pourrait
s'élever à 300 euros si aujourd'hui ces
gestes sont déjà soumis à la
verbalisation la contravention ne
s'élève qu'à 68 euros une sanction
insuffisante selon le député alors 300
euros d'amendé pour ceux qui jettent
leurs masques par terre pour vous
convient c'est dans la musique était la
musique alors qu'est ce que vous en
pensez valérie chabat moi je suis
d'accord
archi d'accord plus que d'accord ça sert
à quoi pendant 55 jours d'applaudir le
personnel soignant d'applaudir les
éboueurs
après les mettre à nouveau en de
recruter parce que kim a ramassé ça qui
va le faire les éboueurs
c'est celui qui a perdu pied donc sinon
mais les éboueurs qu'on a applaudi et
dont on a dit bravo parce qu'ils étaient
au front que s'ils étaient en première
ligne parce que c'est leur boulot était
doux paiera bien sûr et là on les traite
comme ça on jette par terre en disant
c'est pas grave ils ramasseront c'est
n'importe quoi
alors comme tous les procès se munissent
de masse pour plus de protection voici
match de plus en plus polluer nos rues
et 1 français a fait une vidéo dans
laquelle il s'est indigné lorsqu'il a vu
le parking de son supermarché rempli de
masse regardez ça c'est fou j'aimerais
faire passer un message
à toutes ces personnes j'y met les gants
les masses par terre je connaissais pas
les poubelles
franchement est ce que vous pensez
qu'une seule seconde aux personnes qui
vont ramasser ça ça peut être votre mère
votre soeur n'importe qui vote entre
mais c'est vrai sans raison non mais
c'est vrai alors est ce que vous en
pensez les 300 euros au jeu qu'on tue
contrebande d'abord une amende faut que
les municipalités jouent le jeu en étant
suffisamment de poubelles moi je suis
dans une rue 150 mètres de longueur à
peu près elle à cette rue elle a pas de
poubelles se peut qu'il y avait dans ton
sac
même si je le mets dans mon sac petit
lait contaminé par la chose qu'on met
suffisamment de poubelles je suis allé
sur les champs-elysées l'autre jour est
la première nouvelle elle était
complètement rempli un deuxième avait
pas de sacs plastiques et l'écart nature
n'était pas de solution c'est rien les
pays arabes maximisez d'accord avec
heather tu sais que tu as tu as des
difficultés peut-être à trouver des
poubelles
alors tu prends un petit sac plastique
que tu m'aides en toi contenta pas qu'un
sac poubelle pouvait pas de poubelles
jeté l'émoi la gueule tu le fermer ta
tombe est temps de rentrer chez toi nous
on n'a pas d'excusé or aucun nom mais
honnêtement 300 euros ça me choque pas
du tout et l'histoire des poubelles
c'est pas vrai tu peux toujours le
maître et le jeter de la corrosion et
toi parce que là vraiment dans la rue
c'est ce qui jette partout tout le temps
même quand il ya des poubelles qui
tiennent ce genre d'accord c'est honteux
car je sais mais tous les propriétaires
de chiens ce travail avec un sac avec un
sac plastique on met le sac à
l'intérieur c'est pas très compliqué
max tu dois pas connaître mais il existe
même des petits plastique avec des
équipes comme ça tu les fermes
donc il a pas de tension saclay ton
petit mas tu le pli fut le mail en sac
tu te désinfecte les mains et c'est
terminé et ça n'a pas hésité cette rue
mais révoltée des prix celle du sac
poubelle mais juste rajouter un petit
peu plus de poubelles trouver une
solution avant de taxer les pauvres gens
feront à leur gens qui restent à lui de
palaiseau témoin est ce que faudel peut
donner son avis faudel là dessus je
saurai pas moi ouais bah oui voilà la
fraude est là il énerve et l'envié elle
s'est transformée en khaled
moi j'ai même dit 750 euros 300 pour moi
c'est même pas s'ils l'aiment chaud à
partir du moment 2005 l'école pas non
mais je déconne pas à partir du moment
où tu dis aux gens je vous
c'est au visage je jette mon masque et
ça et pareil pour autre chose un papier
de bonbon un paquet de cigarettes tout
est pareil l'art la rue c'est pas une
poubelle la france n'est pas une
poubelle
prenez vos affaires prenez vos poubelles
gardez-le avec vous l'âge d'or je peux
comprendre un petit peu maxime parce que
celle là celle de la photo du
supermarché dont il parle des champs
elysées trek dac tentures dans le
supermarché
souvent tu as pas le truc tu as les
enfants dans la voiture tard en gt
course tu dis l'incivilité il jette les
gants hissbach mais comme vous avez dit
que penser à celui qui va le ramasser
rose et bleu mais qui risque sa vie
lorsque sa vie pour 1400 balle il va
aller ramasser vos merde c'est pas lui
drama il pourrait faire un gros gros
bisous hour parce que je suis en vélo je
tends je me déplace en vélo et je les
vois chaque fois dans leur camion on se
fait des coucous on sent là on
s'embrasse pas parce qu'on peut pas mais
ils sont exceptionnels rassurant mais
ils font un travail les a faits
l'audience ils sont très très
professionnel je les adore voilà jouer
et c'est grâce à eux qu'on peut avoir
une ville propre et ils ont fait un
tweet nous devons leur retrait doit
redistribuer des balles et il ne mérite
pas des masques ces gens regardez ce
qu'ils ont mis un tweet des éboueurs
je vous le dis parce que ça dérange
beaucoup certains français qui trouve ça
inadmissible
en plus d'être dangereux regardez les
piétons en colère sur bfm
depuis le début du déconfinement
l'habitude de porter un masque semble
s'être installée celle de les jeter à la
poubelle beaucoup moins de plus en plus
de masques chirurgicaux et gorille âgées
se retrouvent à même le sol
c'est un vrai scandale il ya des
poubelles tous les 15 20 m mais on sait
pas pourquoi on retrouve tout par terre
en ce moment ce que tous les masques une
admissibles
comprend plage à des poubelles donc on
te met dedans pour que les gens fassent
quelque chose
voilà alors vous avez vu oui et de
tweets des déboires il est
compréhensible
très sexy on voit qu'on n'est pas dans
la même catégorie que le qatar sur le
cac a pris des dispositions pour ceux
qui ne mettent pas de masques dans la
rue mais là la menthe ses passes 350 ces
trois ans de prison et 50 mille dollars
à 110 ans et trois ans de prison et 50
me je veux bien moi je fais trois
extrémistes avec ça parce que c'est quoi
cette mentalité ça veut dire je me suis
protégé
moi j'ai envie de toi j'ai mis mon
masque jeu mais par contre en revanche
les boire ici rêve
oui et non pas parce qu'on est beau
gosse qu'on appel lancez-vous à la
question s'il faisait avait dans les
faits la raison j'ai dit oui et moi je
pense qu'il ya un geste malheureux et
symbolique de faire ça parce que si on
se protège 11
on saura gré autres et on jette par
terre et on s'en fout des autres et on
se dit bah y'a un mec derrière qui va
ramasser
je vais risquer sa vie à lui en mettant
protéger et je trouve que c'est très
grave comme geste d'ouverture très bon
fait jusqu'ici très beau jeu tunisien